j'espère que vous allez bien et que vous
êtes tous bien en sécurité chez écouter
période de confinement c'est pas facile
on ne sait pas comment maintenir une
activité physique régulière et là j'en
suis à vous trois exercices simples à
faire n'importe où chez vous sur votre
balcon dans votre jardin
dans la cuisine ou dans le salon c'est
vous qui choisissez
et vous pouvez les faire à fréquence que
vous
[Musique]
le premier exercice ce sont les montées
de genoux
on va venir monter les jeunes ira au
terme de hanche qui alternaient avec
l'autre on va bien conscient rentrez le
ventre au maximum redresser le bus de
manière à contracter les âges de rhinau
et protéger nos bâtiments pour accentuer
le travail au niveau des cuisses je vais
accélérer le mouvement
[Musique]
le deuxième exercice ce sont les
ouvertures fermetures au niveau des
pieds tout simplement je vais ouvrir et
fermer les pieds quand tu montes sur le
buste droit garde le ventre serré et
toujours pour travailler aux idées
originales et protéger l'eau bas du dos
[Musique]
notre mouvement numéro 3 ce sont les
squats ou flexion d'orange
on va avoir le poids du corps rend très
ancrés dans le sol
oga les abdominaux série on va essayer
de maintenir au maximum le buste ouvert
ici pour ce faire je vais croiser les
bras devant et en descendant le maçon je
n'ai relevé les couvre de manière à
maintenir mon buste droit
donc j'ai en crawl et de méthane dans le
sol je ne descends le bassin vers le sol
et je monte les coudes vers le souffle
et janvier remontant souffle et inspire
[Musique]
je vous conseille de faire cinq
répétitions de chacun de ses mouvements
suivis de 10 répétitions de chaque
alternée puis cinq puis 10,3 fort